A surprising Shanks moment in "One Piece Film:
Red" is sure to please fans
of the mega-popular anime.
“One Piece Film: Red” premiered in
Japanese theaters in August of 2022
and almost immediately reached some major
milestones at the box office. A little more
than one month after its release,
it earned more than 15 billion yen,
placing it among some of the highest-grossing
films in Japanese box office history.
"Let's do this!"
While this latest movie is effectively
a non-canonical side story,
its value to veteran “One Piece”
fans lies partially in how “Film:
Red” incorporates certain characters for the first
time by including Red-Haired Shanks and his pirate
crew in a non-flashback storyline, alongside
longtime protagonist Luffy and his shipmates.
Shanks’ appearance in “Film: Red” is notable in
and of itself, in that Shanks is introduced as
a key character at the series' outset, but has yet
to factor into the story of "One Piece" since then
outside of some peripheral involvement. As it
turns out, "Film: Red" not only includes a rare
Shanks appearance, but demonstrates the power of
his Conqueror's Haki for the first time as well.
Just after the big, climactic battle in "One
Piece Film: Red," some marine admirals attempt
to approach Uta and possibly apprehend Shanks
as well, whose bounty is one of the highest
of all living pirates. In response, Shanks
unleashes a massive outpouring of energy
that collapses every Navy grunt and even
brings some Vice Admirals to their knees.
While Shanks’ use of his Conqueror’s Haki
doesn’t significantly affect the two Admirals,
they decide that a battle against Shanks would
be unwise, given that civilians are present,
and wielding such great power in the midst of
noncombatants may result in unwanted casualties.
In this scene, Shanks’ Conqueror’s
Haki is effectively a warning shot,
meaning that the full range of his powers remains
largely unknown. Nevertheless, Shanks’ defense of
Uta is the closest look at Shanks’ strength
from throughout all of “One Piece” thus far,
be it in anime canon, a non-canonical
side story, or the original manga series.
In the world of “One Piece," Haki is a catch-all
term for a few different kinds of extrasensory
abilities that can only manifest in extreme
conditions. Technically, the Skypiea Arc
introduces Haki for the first time as a power
the residents of its Sky Island call Mantra.
Then, just before the time skip that
bisects the first and second halves
of "One Piece," retired pirate Rayleigh
instructs Luffy on how to utilize Haki,
and his lesson serves as the fans' first proper
introduction to Haki in its various forms.
Rayleigh teaches Luffy about Observation Haki,
which allows its user advanced
forms of perception; Armament Haki,
which can bolster its user’s attack and
defense; and Conqueror's Haki, which is
effectively an expression of willpower that can
physically overwhelm those of weaker disposition.
Hypothetically, anybody can learn to wield
Observation and Armament Haki, but Conqueror's
Haki is a rarity, available only to those lucky
enough to win the genetic lottery, so to speak.
Luffy and Shanks are both capable of wielding
Conqueror’s Haki, and Shanks even lets out a
weak version of his Conqueror's Haki when he meets
with Whitebeard just prior to the Marineford Arc.
It’s only in “Film: Red,” however, that Shanks
lets his Conqueror’s Haki loose, giving viewers
a look at the true extent of his power for the
first time. Tease though it may be, the inclusion
of Shanks’ Conqueror’s Haki in “One Piece Film:
Red” is significant in that it demystifies — even
if just barely — a character shrouded in questions
ever since his introduction at the start of “One
Piece,” and continuing through the nearly 25
years between then and his “Film: Red” debut.
A Reddit thread from September of 2022,
for example, lists five options in a
poll asking users to vote what they
would most like to know about Shanks,
each of which is a separate question
raised about his character at some
point in “One Piece.” In the most-upvoted
response in that thread, one user wrote,
“Where is Shanks, who is Shanks, why is
Shanks, when is Shanks, which is Shanks?”
Meanwhile, the director in charge
of dubbing “One Piece Film:
Red,” Anthony Bowling, highlighted
Shanks’ involvement as one of the
movie’s highlights in an Anime
News Network interview, saying,
"Fans are going to love what they
get to see with him and his crew."
Though Shanks may not be the focus of “Film:
Red,” the fact that he actively engages in a
fight alongside Luffy and his friends marks
a “One Piece” first, imbuing the mysterious
character with some much-needed context as
“One Piece” inches toward its final stretch.